[inaudible]
joining me today as an entrepreneur.
There are co founder of clarity capitol
and the author of God in the crowd,
21st century Judaism talking and welcome
to the Rubin report. Thank you, Dave.
So there's a lot that I want to talk to
you about here because I mentioned to
you right before we started that most
of the conversations that I've had here
about religion have come from
a Christian perspective. Uh,
so adding a Jewish element to this I
thought would be interesting. Uh, your,
your story is kind of fascinating.
You're a Jew from Florida and yet your
religious awakening was because of a
Christian minister in New England. Am I
getting that correct? Yeah, that's right.
Let's start there.
So I, I grew up in boarding
schools, mainly New Hampshire,
so born in Florida and grew up
there until age 10. But then, uh,
then New Hampshire and um,
you know,
I got into Judaism for today describes
as the wrong the wrong reasons. Uh,
I don't know if you've seen the picture
of the boy in the Warsaw ghetto with his
hands, kind of iconic picture that I
saw that when I was 16 years old and it
immediately became where there was looking
at the picture wrong. You know, it's,
it's, it's framed in a way that almost
begs this juxtaposition between the,
the boys innocence and it
was six or seven years old,
angelic face and the Nazi barbarism.
You can see on the right
side of the picture you've
got the Nazis and with their
guns pointed in his, in his
direction. And that never spoke to me.
And I tried to muster anger and
hatred for these Nazis. I couldn't,
all I saw was irrelevance.
You know, this, you know,
I didn't have a good
sense of Jewish history,
but enough of a sense to realize this is,
that was just,
that generation is manifestation
of an age old phenomenon.
The cheese just keeps coming back. It was
in Iraq during the far, who'd you know,
two years earlier. It was with Russian
Cossacks, you know, 30 years earlier this,
this keeps happening.
Um,
but if you look at the left side of
the picture and you can Google it,
boy in the Warsaw ghetto, I think
it's the first thing that comes up.
You see the boy's family
and they're being,
I think that evacuated from the building.
This is the liquidation of the ghetto
in 1943 and they're in this state of
shocked submission.
Uh,
you've see it in their body
language and their expressions.
And I was furious at them for having
aggregated their responsibility to this
boy. How could they not have had a
contingency plan there? The Jews had,
they convinced themselves that they were
Polish and here they were about to be
marched off to their deaths. As far as
I know, everyone in that picture was,
was dead within, within weeks. Um,
but it only took me a week to realize
I'm probably as close as h in age to the
parents as I entered the child.
What's my contingency plan?
And for the first time I started thinking
of myself as a Jew and I come from a
typical American home. All three
of my older brothers, married,
non Jewish women were,
we were pretty much shake out
the way American Judaism does.
And we had no training. I had no
familiarity with Judaism at the time.
So you didn't grow up religious
in any particular right now
I guess not if you going
to boarding school in the
northeast. Right, right. Yeah.
So,
so what happened then? You
have this wake up. So I,
so Reverend Thompson was the school
chaplain. It was a, if Exeter,
it's a prep school in New Hampshire.
Uh,
he was a congregationalist minister.
It's a branch of Calvinism.
That was the kind of original religion
in the Massachusetts Bay colony.
Very open, very old testament focused. Um,
and he knew a lot about Judaism and he
arranged a, a weekly Shabbat dinner,
uh, for the, for the Jewish kids,
which I started going to after that.
It never really meant anything to me up
until that, that, that, that, that moment,
um, and got me into, I don't know if
it's exactly a religion, but a, a,
a sort of a spirituality that's tied to
this ritual of Shabbat as sort of a mode
shift. Um, and you know,
from that point I kind of
dug into everything I could,
took every class that had to do with
Judaism. I read them the Old Testament.
I can,
um,
never became a believer in the
kind of classical sense in,
in the god of scripture. I'm
still still haven't, haven't, uh,
been able to, to access that,
but found my way to Israel,
uh, through that. Yeah. And you ended
up in the Israeli air force. Yeah.
Yeah. That's quite a jump from strangers
to face. Yeah, that's right. Yeah.
What was that like? Um, we're just doing
the biographical stuff. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh, you know, it, it certainly,
it wasn't the plan. I mean, I, I,
I became enamored with Zionism on
a summer tour, kind of a, on a,
something like a birthright type program.
The summer after I saw that
picture and I fell in love.
I think that's the best way
to describe it. You know,
suspended pretty much all logic.
And I think the notion that got me is
this was the opposite of what I saw in
that picture. And it took me until
the end to realize that, that the,
that the thing that struck me the most
was the lack of dignity in that picture.
We had no agency,
we were just victims.
And it was just such a terrible way to
kind of define ourselves and think of
ourselves as a people.
And you know,
when I asked Jewish friends at Exeter
or even my, my, my family, you know,
is there a contingency plan? What do
we do? And my grandfather was German.
I think he conceived of himself when he
was, you know, my age at the time, uh,
as German way before he was Jewish,
until he was notified.
You're no longer German. Uh, and
luckily that happened in 1936 and 1990,
39 so he could still leave. Um,
what happens if we get that call?
What's our, what's our plan? And people
thought that was a crazy question.
That's just not,
it's just not a pleasant thing to have
to think about who talks about that.
And in Israel,
I saw people who had not just asked that
question with all the courage that it
takes to, you know, you need to
muster in order to ask. But they,
they'd answered it and he was dignity
and it was, it was intoxicating to me.
And so I,
I,
at that point I think realized I was
going to make my way somehow to Israel
whether I was going to live there
or just be very involved. Um,
and when I finally did move,
you know,
I understood that military service was
kind of the ticket to full membership. Um,
and so I, I did what
I was told. I ended up
and, but ending up in the air force is
not an easy route for that ticket. Yeah.
Turns probably the most complex
route, I would imagine. Yeah, it was,
at the time it was, it was
very calm, very complicated,
and it certainly wasn't an nap.
She'll fit. Uh, for me, I'm required a lot
of, a lot of adjustments along the way.
Um, but, uh, but that, that,
that is where I ended up. Yeah.
And kind of what I think brought me to
the book ultimately is that, you know,
I found myself,
um,
it's such a focused and
intense experience, you know,
the academies is just extremely, uh, um,
it's just a concentrated source of
knowledge and skills dump. Uh, and,
and it doesn't let up after you,
you graduate that I really never had
time to examine what is this, what, what,
what exactly am I pursuing?
What is Judaism? What is
Israel? I didn't know Israel.
I knew a very narrow cut,
the kind of the several hundred people
in the aircrew community and he was,
so that's why I knew it was Israel for
me. And it's not reflective of, of,
of society. And you know,
it took me probably,
you know, eight or nine years of service
to kind of step back and say, okay,
now can I at the time to
investigate what this is. Um,
and that was actually a moment of crisis
because I had already done things that
I couldn't take back. I mean,
you know, there's a very
combat intensive decade, uh,
the 1990s in Israel. Um, you know what,
what it started sort of as a romantic
sort of teach for America or Peace Corps
type type adventure for a college kid
ended up being something that I couldn't,
couldn't erase.
There's things I could not take back and
I had to really understand what it is
that, that I was, I was doing there
and I started kind of a search.
And what is Judaism exactly?
Yeah.
All right.
So that's a perfect set up on a,
on a personal note for everything that
the book is about and that we're going to
talk about here.
So first I was trying to think of the
right way to do this interview because
it's a little weird talking about Judaism
in a religious sense because it's an
ethnicity and a culture and a religion.
And usually when people
are talking about religion,
you can remove those two other things
because people are from all parts of the
world. And have different, uh, you
know, traditions and all of that,
but Jews have the same traditions and
those are at least at some level related
to religion and all that.
So what's the easiest way to start that
conversation about culture and tradition
and religion? All, all in one mixed bag?
Well that is very much at the heart of
this book is that we were called upon the
generations of Jews who are alive today
are called upon to redefine Judaism.
And the, and what kind of the
premise I start with is in our story,
it's almost a 4,000 year story.
We have two episodes of fundamental
reinvention Judaism's constantly evolving.
We've always changed. There's no
generation that it'd be quite the same.
Judy's with their kids that they
inherited from their parents,
but there were two
fundamental reinventions.
One is the exodus where we leave Egypt
unclear what we are exactly where some
group, but it's unclear
exactly what, what it is. Um,
and 40 years later arrive in the
promise land with sovereignty,
right?
We control ourselves and we're governed
by a book of law which will stay with us
for, for as long as I've story
laughs and it's still with us today.
It's a fundamental reconfiguration
of, of, of what this is,
what this enterprise is Judaism. And
the second is the Roman expulsion, uh,
from, from Israel. And in the year one 35,
which is a bright,
the end of sovereignty in Israel at the
end of a geographic cause you didn't all
show up there in 1948.
We did that later. Okay,
let's just dispel that right
now. Yes, we for exactly. Okay.
So here we are a people configured very
much like any other people around us,
the Phoenicians and Nabataeans, we looked
like any province of the Roman Empire,
uh, in, in, in most
ways. And then off we go,
we're scattered to hundreds
of nodes around the world, uh,
with an already complex orthodoxy that
was to continue evolving dramatically
over the next 2000 years. No
central conductor, no pope.
The officiating over our evolution.
Almost no contact between
most of the notes, right?
If you are often some shtetl in
Poland and I was in Casa Blanca,
we didn't even know about each other
and we certainly were not in touch with
each other for most of that period.
What I would bet against the idea that
there'd be a coherent identity called Jew
1800 years after that
event. It is, you know,
it's something that I think
bears in investigation. Um,
but you think there's a reason for that.
And that's what this book is about. I do.
And I think that was the
second fundamental reinvention.
We, we're not, we, we, we,
we reconfigured ourselves at that point
where we became a people that was about
a set of questions and
debating a set of questions,
ethical questions at
which we still do today.
I think we're on the eve of a
third fundamental reinvention.
And that comes from the fact,
or were, or at least the,
what I posit is that antisemitism is no
longer defining force for the Jews for
1800 years. It was we most,
for most of that period,
we didn't have the choice to be, you
know, we talk about religion, you know,
we use the word faith and religion sort
of interchangeably in the United say,
Hey, there's not a central
component of Judaism. Uh,
it not in the way we define ourselves
and not the way we were defined. Know,
no one asks you what you believe before
you stepped into the gas chambers, right?
That was a, you could be
secular, you could be an atheist,
you can be getting matter. You were
a Jew. So it wasn't a religion,
it wasn't a faith. Uh, that, that,
that, and I think in that sense,
the Nazis got us right
in many ways is it's not,
not really about whether
we believe or not. Um,
which is why they're seemingly
are so many Jewish atheist,
which we can get into how that works and
has worked throughout Jewish history.
I mean, faith is not a precondition
to, uh, to Jewish observance,
even orthodox Jewish observance. But
what we're facing today, I think is,
is certainly not precedented
in the last 2000 years,
is that 90% of us live in the
United States and in Israel.
Two jurisdictions that I think are
largely devoid of antisemitism in,
in any practical day to day way.
I, I have, uh, you know, uh,
maybe a correction is on the left.
There is something happening today
that we should maybe talk about.
It's a fault in the book. I'm,
I'm maybe too dismissive of, of a,
of that and I hope it's a
passing, you know, fed. But
essentially in this country,
being Jewish is a choice today.
It wasn't for our grandparents generation
were Jewish kind of in the sense that
you are in Europe today, right? If you're
French, a French Jew, you're a Jew.
I mean to, to, to, to other French people
that, that, that, that that's how we're,
we're, we're, uh, looked at, in this
country, you are truly an American.
And in Israel you are truly Israeli.
Judaism is a choice.
That's our challenge.
It's a huge opportunity because for the
first time I think we can write our own
script throughout the Jewish world,
not just in Israel.
We can decide what this is,
what is this enterprise. Um,
but it's also a threat because right now
and if we see what's happening in this
country and it's much easier
to track it in this country,
we're voting with our feet.
We are marrying ourselves
out of existence. Uh, which,
you know, the, for the First Section of
the book, sculpture, there'd be Jews.
I think we have to start with
that fundamental question
and ask it honestly and
bravely.
Yeah.
So, so why is your answer
to that question? Yeah.
Because I think a certain amount of
people would say, all right, well that,
so I would,
I was going to ask you this at the end,
but when I had my first sit
down with Sam Harris, who's,
who's obviously one of the most well
known atheists, but he was born Jewish,
I don't think he considers himself
Jewish in a, in any real sense,
but I don't want to speak for him
specifically. We did talk about this.
There's a couple of years ago and he
said that there would be a nice end story
to the Jews,
which is that they would all give up on
all of the superstition and all the rest
of it and just sort of evolve out of it.
And that would be a pleasant ending
that that's his basic premise on that.
But that's not your premise. Um, so
I'd love to hear, so why is the answer
well for what I think I would agree
with is if we are going to end,
that's the best way to do it for sure.
Okay. Uh, the atheist is the dreamer,
but, but I would say,
look, I mean, when I,
when I look at what Sam Harris
has, I think tried to do,
um, over time, which to me,
and I don't know if he'd put it this way,
but to me it's very much a inventing
a religion that doesn't require faith,
right? Or an ethical system. Maybe
religion is, is the wrong word. And that,
you know, there's a lot that's wired in
us from the Savannah, right? A lot of of,
of, of, of altruism, altruism
and morality that is wired.
And let's build on that. Let's take
the golden rule as a sort of a, as a,
as a starting point. Um, and,
and build on that. I like that.
I think the issue with it is,
you know,
I use the wisdom of crowds
as a, as, as a sort of,
as a framework for Jewish governance
in diaspora. And I believe in that.
I think there is something
quite compelling about this
notion of, of, of, of, of,
of a group defining itself in governance
and governing itself through, uh,
through crowd wisdom. It's a great kind
of noise cancellation, um, uh, mechanism.
And this is what you'd say is,
is sort of the lack of the top down part
of Judaism because there is no pope,
not everybody's or we're not all pointing
one way for this or looking for wisdom
in that direction. Correct. It's
coming from the people. Yeah. It's,
it requires diversity,
requires independent thought that,
that that's Jewish at it's [inaudible].
Hmm.
One of the issues and you see
this in markets all the time,
markets at the end of the day,
financial markets are, are you know,
in in many ways an exercise in, in crowd
wisdom. We're trying to divine the truth.
What is the value of that stock?
What is the present value of
future earnings of this company?
That's what we're all trying to
guess at, uh, at, at its essence.
And one thing you'll find is
if you look at it long term,
if you look at chart the s and p 500 for
the last hundred years, all right? Uh,
you'll see that the incredible
how closely, you know,
if you look at the actual present value
of future earnings and retrospective of,
of the, of the securities in
that, in that, in that index, uh,
you'll find that the market is incredibly
good at getting it right over long
periods of time. But zoom in on any
short timeframe, right? Three years,
five years, it's always
wrong, almost always wrong.
The market is almost always wrong
in, in, in the, in the short term.
So the notion of, of inventing a, a,
a code of ethics from scratch leaves
us hostage to the sensibilities of our
generation. You know, I often has
to tell it's a tough question say,
but had I been born a Lutheran in
Germany, uh, and come of age in the 1930s,
can I say I would definitely would
not have joined, uh, the, uh, that,
that the Nazi movement,
of course not most people,
most people are verbal question to face,
but I think it's an important
one to think about it, right?
So we're all hostage to kind of
the prevailing winds of our era.
What I think Judaism does and the reason
I think it has valued not just to Jews
but,
but to humanity is it as a
methodically recorded history of
the evolution of our ethics as,
as, as, as a species, right? It's a,
it's a critically important reference
point and it's a unique reference.
Right now there's a record of, of papal
edicts that also goes back a long way.
And I think it's also extremely
valuable. It's different though, right?
It's the opinion of one man,
very learned man in general. But,
but it's one man.
Well,
we have now is a snapshot of the crowd
wisdom of a generation on questions that,
you know,
and Judy is always [inaudible] always
great about kind of highlighting the,
the two tensions, right? Hillel
and Sean, you go into a wedding,
you're introduced to the bride, uh, and
the people or person introduced me as his,
isn't she beautiful? And you don't think
she's beautiful. What do you say? Okay,
so Sean, I will say, well, the, the most
important guiding ethic is truth, right?
Honesty is, is, is a,
is a, is a critical, uh,
value that we be pursuing. I would come
down on the side of tell the truth. No,
I don't think you're beautiful.
That's a tough one. At the wedding,
the wedding yellow was saying how humanity
is a more understand that honesty I'm
giving you to do for sure.
I, I get your point. However,
here's where I think the optimism that,
that, that is the exercise of Judaism.
It has been. Um, uh, I, I think forever,
but we've recorded a history of the
evolution of the both the consensus views
and the dissenting views on a host
of topic. That is Tom would, that is,
that is that exercise.
So when we use a term like justice today,
justice is not a natural phenomenon.
It's a human invention.
And we could have invented
in a lot of different ways.
We did invent it in a
lot of different ways,
are kind of prevailing concept of justice
100 years ago is quite different from
what it is today.
And let's have the humility to admit
that a hundred years from now we will
probably evolve significantly further.
The fact that we have a record of
the trajectory of that evolution,
I'll show some justice, but on,
on hundreds of ethical questions.
That's a gift of Judaism. And to
me personally, I've yet to meet.
It's a privilege to be a
link in that chain. I, I want
that. I mean, that's, that,
that's exciting to me. So that is why
when you have three Jews at the table,
you have four opinions based on 100%
yes, that's right. It's annoying,
but it's got,
it was loud and there's a lot of
yelling involved. So, all right,
so there's a lot to do there,
but let's just go to the god
part of that first because,
because there is this
interesting phenomenon with,
with I think Jews describing
themselves as Jewish atheist.
That's all right. Um, and, uh,
how I think the average person
hearing that would go, well,
how does that make any sense?
How can you say you were a member of
a religion if you don't believe in the
basic tenant of the religion,
right?
You could open up any old testament or
any book that they're going to have at
any synagogue in anywhere,
a lot about God.
So how can you be a Jew and then not
necessarily believe, uh, be a believer?
Well, so I think the,
the notion of, of God in,
even in Jewish scripture is
actually quite fluid, right? The,
it's not just some guy with a beard
who cares about what you eat. Right?
We refer to that entity and the masculine
and the feminine in the singular and
the plural. It's a very
evolving, uh, notion.
And as we get to kind of
the Post Biblical era,
I think some of the greatest Jewess sages
of history have questionable faith in
the god of scripture. My monities
himself I'm not convinced is a,
is a true believer in the god of scripture
as, as laid out in the Old Testament.
Um, what I, I do think
though is there is a,
there's tremendous value in having a, a
reference point. And to me the notion,
and I think a lot of, um, may
be more, more devout people
will take issue with it.
I understand that and that this is kind
of part of the debate that we have to
have
an invented God can be just
as meaningful and as valuable,
certainly as a spiritual rallying point,
as a revealed God.
And we can actually work together if
you're a true believer, so to speak.
And I'm not, we can work together. I've
been thinking in terms of, uh, of, uh,
if you and I start a business that makes
circles, that's, that's our product. Uh,
anybody can come in and
order a circle of any size.
You just tell us the radius and we'll
make your, your, your, your, your circle.
We need a point to draw that sort
of circle around, right? Yeah.
We need a point in a radius.
That's it.
Now I could be of the view that we
can put that point on the ceiling,
on the floor in space. It doesn't
matter. It really doesn't matter.
As long as we have the radius and a point,
we can make the circle.
You can be of the view that no,
I'm sorry that this circle is not kosher
unless the point around which is drawn
is right in the middle of that wall.
We can work together because, okay,
so let's do it. Or I don't care where
it goes. You do care where it goes.
Let's put it where you want
it. That's fine. As long as,
and this is an exercise very
much in love and in humility,
as long as you're okay with the
idea that I think you're crazy,
but that it needs to be in the middle,
that wall.
And I'm okay with you think I'm a heretic,
that, uh, that I, I don't, I don't care.
The result is the same. We have our
circle and we can work together.
And in many ways I think that is,
that is Judaism. And if, you know, we,
we've conflated faith with religion in
this country and that's a very Christian
notion. It's not a Jewish notion. We,
faith is not really a critical
part of, of, of, of Judaism.
So does that explain why someone like
Albert Einstein who certainly, you know,
God doesn't play dice
with the universe who,
so he wasn't a believer in
any sort of traditional sense,
although maybe in the way that
you are describing it. Um,
he was extremely proud of being Jewish
and who was almost the president that he
was going to be the first
president of Israel. Um,
and obviously he lived through a
Germany during the Holocaust. So, um,
or at least was a child at the
beginning of it. So, um, that,
that type of person though seems to exist.
There's a,
there's a lot of that you go to hospitals
in New York City where they have like
a Shabbat elevator for doctors and that
seems very strange and yet it's somehow
kind of functions. So that's just
a piece of everything that yeah,
you're talking about basically.
Yeah. I mean, I think, you
know, it's, it's, it sounds,
sounds crazy, but operating system
is a, is a, is a better term to me.
It captures Judaism better than
religion does. Right? It's a code, uh,
through which we w w uh, through which
rapid or a lens through which we, we, we,
we see the world. Um, we don't have
to see it the same way. It's okay.
Yeah. So, so what about the
cultural and traditional part of it?
Because most Jews,
so I grew up in long island.
Everyone was either Jewish or
Greek or Italian basically, but,
but cer a certain ethnic identity that
most of them came from Ellis Island.
You know, their grandparents are
saying came from Ellis Island,
eventually lived in Brooklyn or Queens,
and then they made it to long island.
But I grew up, obviously around
a lot of Jewish people. Um,
most people weren't religious per se,
but there was a huge cultural identity.
There's a sense of humor,
mostly a sense of humor,
I would say perhaps
more than anything else.
A certain way of talking to each other.
There are certain like Seinfeld in
way of looking at the world. Right.
Do you think that is
enough to sustain something
long enough? No, I think it's great.
It's essential. It's, it's more, uh, uh,
an outgrowth of, of the core
than, than, than core itself.
Um, but no, it's not. It's,
um, you know, uh, again, we,
we need to ask ourselves, do we want
this people to continue, uh, uh,
existing? Uh, if we do,
we need a much more tangible,
much more accessible,
much more definable,
a source of identity than humor is
difficult to kind of put your finger on.
I mean, I, and, and we know,
we both know what we're talking
about when we say Jewish humor.
We know what we're talking about
when we say Jewish thinking,
this is a Jewish way. If they go below
of looking at a problem or like w we,
we get that.
But it is a little bit too nuanced I think
to communicate to certainly to future
generations or to, to other
people. So what is it?
So what's needed then in this
vision of the future that,
that you think would be the
right way to continue this,
this incredible and also tragic story.
W what's the best way to,
right. So the good news is I see
a path to making it, not tragic,
but still incredible. Um, and it
is a shift in our story, right?
This is even that right
there is a huge part, right?
It's sort of acknowledging like it's
a little bit weird to look back at the
history of our ancestors and go,
man,
there was a lot of depth here.
There was a lot of horrible things that
happened and I've talked about it many
times. I have family members on both
sides have died in the Holocaust.
I have family members that live in
Israel now. I've, you know, that people,
that it's a history of pogroms and
genocides and holocausts and all of these
things that make it a little bit tough to,
to look at the future or something like
that. Yeah. Look, I, I hear that. I, um,
you know, I've, I've, I've,
I've had conflicting feelings
on using that history as a,
as an anchor of identity,
even though many of us do,
and for many of us it's still
relevant. You know, to be clear,
you certainly feel Israel is
changing that I suppose. So that's,
that gets to what you said in Israel.
You feel it right in Israel that you do
feel that in a way that I don't think
you do in the United States, which
is you're in the Middle East. Yeah.
And our neighbors have not reconciled
themselves with the notion of Jewish
sovereignty. And we see that. And it
might be difficult to see from here,
especially if you, and if it's,
you're not, it's not your day to day.
I understand that. It was crazy. Greedy.
Jews want a country that's about six miles
wide at, won't be in it. Right. Do know,
man. Right. Never write enough,
right? Yeah. I mean, if,
if you kind of look at a few
of it doesn't, it doesn't
take a ton of analysis,
but what, what are the other
Jewish options in the Middle East?
We have 7.2 million Jews in Israel. Are
they supposed to go back to bed? Baghdad.
Damascus.
Cairo where you're supposed to get the
entire Middle East has been ethnically
cleansed of 100% of its Jews. 100%.
There's one guy in Egypt, isn't there?
Why I read about that? I've met that
one. I'm not, I met the one guy,
I think he's gone but did meet the guy.
Yeah. The guy that claimed he was a Jew,
I don't know. Right, right, right.
So you look at that and you know,
with the tragedy of that,
assuming that the Baghdadi
Jewish community is a thousand
years older than Islam
itself and it's been eradicated zero,
uh,
there is no formula for existing
as a Jew in the Middle East,
outside of Israel.
It doesn't work.
I mean this th th th there are
no exceptions to that rule, that,
that that's clear enough.
And when you live in Israel,
it's, it, you know, it, uh,
I think it's something that, that,
that, that, that, that's quite clear.
So we're not in a place where we
can escape that anymore now or yet.
I think I'm an optimist in terms of,
uh,
Israel's eventual acceptance among the
community of nations in the Middle East.
Again,
I think there's a lot of reasons to
think that's happening right now,
that sort of a whole other show about
geopolitics, I guess, than anything else.
But I think they've started
to just accept, wow,
these guys are here and they're actually
giving us water and a whole bunch of
other things
we can do together. Yeah,
yeah. Agreed. Um, so,
so anyhow, I, you know, I, I don't think
we can divorce ourselves completely from
our past, nor should we, I think that's,
that, that's fine. But as
an anchor for identity,
particularly in the United
States where, you know, the Ma,
my children's generation in this country
sees the Holocaust is kind of ancient
history. That's not that it has no
bearing on their lives. You know,
they see themselves as, you
know, very, very privileged.
Um, you know, well educated,
uh, you know, uh,
Americans with a great future
Americans and Israelis with,
with a great future wherever they end up
in either country, you know, they, um,
so selling them on Jewish identity
through the Holocaust or through,
you know,
the inquisition or through or through
that part of Jewish history for now is not
working. And I hope it continues
not working. Right. I mean,
a lot of people have reacted to
the book by saying, you know,
one good wave of antisemitism and we
solve your problem. So that's, you know,
I hope, first of all, let's look,
should we hope for that? I mean,
that doesn't sound like a, and it's also
pathetic notion of that, that we can't,
without antisemites, there
can't be Jews. I mean,
that's the w w w w there's so
much more to this legacy than,
than hatred and persecution so much more.
There's so much richness here and and,
and beauty that we can
develop and now steer.
Now that we have the agency to
actually steer ourselves, let's do it.
Let's claim it. This is, this is I, to me,
a very exciting moment in Jewish history
with with a threat associated with it.
Okay.
Yeah. It's interesting because
right now in America and you,
you referenced this a little bit earlier,
that with what's going on with the left,
if you were to ask me where
antisemitism is in America right now,
are there some KKK members that might
be far right extremists? Yes, there are,
and they've always been here.
I don't think there's any more of them.
I don't think they have
any institutional power.
I think the media makes it seem like
they're everywhere and they're just not,
they call everybody and Nazi. I just
don't think that's real. I don't,
I just simply don't think it's real.
Yeah.
Where I am concerned about antisemitism
though is what is happening on the left
that Jews are no longer victims and they
love victimhood because they'd be view
victimhood is virtuous and now
Jews are thought of as white.
So my brown brother-in-law,
Reggie's parents were both refugees,
kicked out of their countries, is now
privileged in the, you know, it's,
he's a immigrant at our end child
of refugees and, and he's Brown,
but he's now privileged and I see a much
more what actually I think is systemic
racism because they're trying to build
this all into the system of how we view
each other. I see that really
hardening on the left and,
and I think that's why so many, you
know, I talk about this all the time,
why I see minority groups breaking from
leftism. I see this happening with,
with black people. There's a lot
of evidence that it's happening.
It's how I see it
happening with gay people.
I see it happening with Jewish people.
I think it's happening
with Asian people now. Um,
so in a certain way I'm hopeful
because Jews are going, ah,
the old thing maybe isn't
working the way it always has.
So I, I hope I'm not naive. I'm
an optimist on that as well. In,
in that I think the ideologies that have,
you know,
I think for very natural and good
reasons have surfaced, right?
We're always going to be overshooting
and undershooting truth. That's,
that's that, that's us more,
you know, human beings, um,
are in many ways self defeating,
right?
Intersectionality as an
exclusionary ideology versus as a,
as a framework for understanding
social phenomena. I mean,
it's collapsing in the face
of Louis Farrakhan right now.
How are you supposed to be gay
and still be on board with this?
How are you supposed to be a Jew and
still be on board with this? And I think,
I feel like we're probably even,
I mean if you look at what to
me is a shame because you know,
blacks and Jews in this country have
been kindred spirits for over a hundred
years. You know, we found that the NAACP,
this was our fight black education,
that the schools in the south
were Jewish on the resort.
We marched and died in Mississippi.
The thing I was going to say,
most of those people in those pictures
marching with Martin Luther King,
most of the white people
were Jewish. Yeah, yeah.
Right.
So this is a false divide,
which I think ultimately corrects itself.
I was just speaking to a group, uh,
recently about, um,
black lives matter. Um,
and you know, to me this, this
ultimately has to be self correcting.
You take the people who really have been
on your side and have tied your fate to
yours and for some reason have decided
that they're on the other side. Right?
If you look at the 2016 social policy
agenda of the black lives matter movement,
um,
it has one foreign policy clause.
It's there to condemn the genocidal
apartheid state of Israel. Yeah.
It's actually for some reason the
Palestinian population keeps going up.
This is the worst. Genocide were
terrible or bad numbers, right? Yeah.
Just can't get anything. Right.
But you kind of look at that.
And if black lives matter,
which they do to me, you know,
my wife and I adopted two door Foria
and refugees 10 years ago in Israel.
They live in Israel now.
Uh,
there is a genocide going on right now
in Darfur during 300,000 or 400,000
people killed because they are black.
The foreign policy agenda that you chose
in a movement who flies the flag of
black lives is not that.
It's,
it's that I have to believe is ultimately
going to collapse under the weight its
own, uh, did just an
unreasonableness that doesn't work.
Does it make sense?
Interesting though?
Cause I don't see that as a
tension between blacks and
Jews cause I really don't
see that changing. I see it. I see
that as a tension between short,
what I would say basically are
crazy leftist versus everyone else.
Pretty much it. Yeah. That just
happens to be a political slice.
I don't think that's really a racial
tension. Does that, does that make sense?
Yeah. No, I hear that. I mean
I hit the plus plenty of a,
a black interlocutors who see it
exactly as, as we do, by the way,
who also sake I kinda
like we do about Judaism.
Victim Hood is a terrible
basis for identity.
It's a self defeating and it's a
self fulfilling prophecy. Ultimately,
if you'd let you know, let, let's aspire
to something better than that. Yeah.
By the way, not ignoring
the past, right? There is,
there is a legacy here that we of course
have to acknowledge if we're gonna,
if we're going to do anything about it,
but,
but does that also explain the,
the endless sort of focused hatred
of Israel from the modern left and I,
not just in America,
but in virtually every country or the UN,
which is basically the biggest crock in
the history of the world. Why they all,
you know, for every one
condemnation of another country,
there's 27 against Israel
or something, right? Yeah.
Completely insane that Jews in Israel
are no longer victims and the left loves
victims. So now that you're not victims
anymore, you automatically are the enemy.
I would argue it's better to not be a
victim and to be alive than to be liked by
a bunch of people who want
you to live like slaves, but,
right. Um, but does that,
is it really that simple to boil it down?
Cause I think it's pretty close to that.
Okay. I, I, I wish that were
the best explanation for it.
MMM.
I fear that antisemitism,
it might be a better,
a better explanation because there,
there are plenty of countries.
Singapore is succeeding
wildly. Incredible. Singapore
is an incredible story.
There no UN resolutions against Singapore.
That's not something that, uh, uh,
so,
well, no, I mean, I mean the history
of the Jews was, you guys were on the,
you were the, on the victim side of
this whole thing and we liked it.
We liked it that way, that
that's the way it was. Right.
And there's some weird thing about like
the chosen people think about that.
It's like, ah, I see. I guess they're
not that chosen or something like that.
But my favorite line ever rise from
fiddler on the roof, which is, you know,
I know we're the chosen people.
I just wish we could be chosen for
something else. Right. But, but,
so I don't mean that in terms of
the success of a country, I think,
I mean the uniqueness of the success of
a country that was so associated with
being slaughtered and everything
else that no longer acts as a victim.
That bat flips the
whole thing on its head.
Yeah. Like it could be that,
I mean, I just see the,
the suspension of logic in a lot of the
condemnations of Israel that I think
you're talking about reminds me very much
of the suspension of logic in classic
European antisemitic tropes,
right. The blood libel,
things that don't really make
sense. Right. That's a [inaudible].
MMM.
It rhymes with that.
And the fact that we're this,
the Jews in this case and Jews in that
case seat seems to be not a coincidence.
Yeah. Unfortunately
wished. I, you know, I, I,
and I try to see it differently because
it feels like a cop out to say, oh,
it's antisemitism. Uh, it's tough for
me to find a, an explanation of it.
You know, things like, uh, you can't be
a Zionist and a feminist, right? You're,
you're gonna pick the first
liberal democracy to elect
a female head of state to
say you can't be that and
a feminist as strange,
better women's representation on corporate
boards and incorporate managements
than the United States. That's the
country that feminists can't, can't,
can't get onboard with when it's
neighborhood is exactly the opposite of,
remind me again, are they
throwing gays off roofs in Israel?
Right, exactly. Yeah. Right. I
mean, I think a Tel Aviv for,
forgot which magazine put
it on, uh, number one, uh,
gay city on earth. Right?
It's, how is it that, you know,
Spanish pride parade. We'll
boycott Israeli marchers
or the Chicago Dyke March.
We'll throw people out for
having a star of David on the,
these things don't make sense.
And to me,
it very much rhymes with a w with
something from our, from our history.
I think we're at a place where we can,
I don't know,
maybe it's too much to
say safely ignore it,
but it doesn't have to factor into
our lives in any huge way in Israel.
You don't feel that in your day to day,
you don't feel embattled or you know, uh,
um, you know, uh, that, that, that,
that we're not glued to the TV to watch,
you know, UN votes and see what happens.
We can't, okay. We know that story.
We were literally sublimating
that thing anyway.
Yeah, true. Yeah, that's right. So
hopefully these are signs, you know,
cycles that were worked themselves out.
But, you know, um, again, I, I, uh,
I'm kind of a,
almost allergic to the,
to anything that might lead us to
define ourselves on those terms.
Let's not let the haters define us.
We're in a place where we have the
agency to do it ourselves. And that,
that to me is the,
that's the exciting part of this.
But that's why I wrote the book.
So with all this in my own,
one of the things that I'm always amazed
by is when they do that happiness index,
right? That world happiness
index that comes out every year.
Israel is usually somewhere
between like 10 and 15 on that.
And yet if you turn on CNN and all
you ever see or bombs blowing up and
terrorist attacks and buses
blowing up and all that,
now there obviously is some connection
to the good things that you're talking
about and the ability to still be happy
in a pretty rough part of the world.
What do you see that as if you believe
in the premise that I'm offering?
Right. Well, I mean you, you've spent
time in Israel. It's, it is a happy place.
It's not no Israeli surprised by those,
by those rankings. We w we get it when we,
and I, and I think there's a
certain appreciation of that. Yeah.
I think a big piece of it
is community and you know,
a part of why the book is,
I think getting the reception that it's
getting right now is there's a thirst
for, for that. Um,
in many ways we're losing it or maybe
there's a pendulum that swings between,
you kind of think we can conceive
of ourselves as individuals.
We can conceive of ourselves as cells in
an organism called community, religion,
country, what would it, however
you choose to define it. Um,
it seems that we're kind of
on an individualistic, uh,
extreme of the swing of that,
of, of that pendulum today.
And there is a communal itch that needs
to get scratched. I think that's, that,
that that's wired into us, uh, right now.
And one of the things that Israel is
getting right and there are many things
that his is getting wrong. As
I, as I described in the book,
one of the things that Israel is getting
right is it is a community and a sense
of I have your back and you have mine.
We have responsibility for each other.
Uh, we're, we're not just
individuals in some rat race.
We are th th th th we are
part of something bigger.
How would you think of
that do you think is a,
is a Jewish Jewish ethic per se versus
the fact that everyone has to go to the
army, which then would obviously create
a very similar ethic? Yeah, so I,
I think they're both at play.
Um,
it is a profoundly Jewish ethic though.
I kind of, if you look at other diasporas
look what this Jewish community in
United States did in the seventies and
eighties on behalf of Soviet Jewry,
right? People they hadn't met before,
people that if they hadn't had any
association with for generations, uh,
but still felt that these are people
we need to stick our necks out for and
write checks for and March four and
protest for a and get them out and liquid
Israeli Jewry did write a population of
four and a half million people absorbed
over a million immigrants
in a year and a half.
It's a huge nut to swallow from if a
fiscal perspective from a social and, and,
and did it unquestioningly of course
it was the obvious thing where we were
going to do, we do look out
for each other. And that is a,
that is a Jewish notion to look what
we did for Yemeni jewelry and Ethiopian
Jewry and Iraqi Jewry.
We take responsibility for each other.
So that is a very Jewish ethic
and it permeates Israeli society.
You can feel that. And that's,
uh, that's part of it. And Yeah,
and I think part of it is through
military service. Right? You, you,
you do get exposed in a real,
uh, many of us do, at least in a,
in a, in a, in a frontal way to people
who have genocidal intentions towards you.
Luckily they don't have the means to,
to, to fulfill those, um, the, the, the,
those intentions, but they're pretty
obvious. I mean, it's not something you,
anybody who serves, we'll
see that. I don't think that.
So does that make you happy? I don't know,
but certainly fought, forges a sense of,
of community, I think. Yeah. Um,
you have some stories about combat and
how that relates to all of this. Yeah.
I mean, uh, you, you know, one of the
things I try to talk about is, you know,
if we're going to revive a
Jewish spark, which, you know,
I think two or three generations of Jews
in Israel and the United States have
tried to extinguish, um, uh, in many ways.
What are the starting points, you know,
what are their embers that we can figure?
What do you mean by that?
That two or three generations
of Jews have tried to Accenture?
You mean just sort of run from
religion or also if you look at it?
So I segment Israeli society and it's my
segmentation. I, I just pay, people have,
you know,
issues with this specific segmentation.
But I do see it and I think a
lot of people see it as well. Um,
when we look at the notion
of Jewish statehood,
there are three separate constituencies
in Israel that are defined in my view by
what their vision is for Jewish statehood.
And these are visions that
were never reconciled. They
should have been but, but,
but they weren't. Instead, in 1947,
we came up with an agreement to split
them into different communities and that's
how we are in Israel today.
There was a community they call the
secularists that really want a harbor,
a safe, safe haven for the Jews
that is structured as a democracy.
That's pretty much it.
That was hurtles, vision.
That's how Bob's vision with
some Jewish trappings, you know,
the national holiday should be Jewish
holidays, but not much more than that.
We're not going to have the government
prescribed religious practice to the
citizenry. That's, that's the
secular verse vision. There
was a theocratic vision,
um,
which had very few adherence in 1947 when
the status quo agreement with which is
the agreement that's cemented those
constituencies into different camps.
There are very few adherence with
almost no political ambitions today.
That group is big and growing massively
and has maximalist political ambitions
to turn Israel into a theocracy.
And then there's what I call
a territorial as vision,
which says the whole land of Israel is a,
is a,
a god given gift.
And there is no human prerogative
in relinquishing it, right?
We can't step away from it. These
are three competing camps, uh, in,
in, in Israeli society. Uh,
whose views were going
to have to reconcile.
When I talk about
extinguishing Judaism though,
it was the secularist who ruled Israel
certainly until 1977 and I would argue to
great extents to, to, to this day, and
the original secularists were Russians,
right? The arc is the architects of
Jewish statehood. We're central Europeans,
right? Hungarians, Austrians, you
know, her Hertzel, uh, [inaudible], uh,
Israel's angle that that crowd,
the actual builders were Russians.
They were the eastern Europeans who
were escaping pogroms when they came to
Israel.
And these guys came at the dawn of
Bolshevism and the czar was their enemy.
And you know, the, the,
the Bolshevik resolute revolution was
largely Jewish from the leadership down to
the, to, to the, to the,
to the ground troops.
Antisemitism was so embedded in Russia
that it became very quickly clear as
Trotsky under understood to light.
We're still the Jews and we're
not welcome in this enterprise.
But people who have had drunk,
that socialist Koolaid came to Israel and,
and that was the elite of our country
for the first, you know, 50 years of,
of its existence and
certainly pre-state right.
The kibbutzniks the guys who taught
me to be in Israeli, right. The,
the guys who I was with at the academy,
we're primarily kibbutzniks. That was,
that was Israel's elite.
So they were like small scale socialists
at some level either. Yeah. I mean,
when I, I'd spend weekends on, you know,
my friends keep with same and there was
a Komisar that was a title in the boots.
I don't know how small scale, I
mean, this was, uh, uh, that, that,
that ethic has more or less died.
But what's, what's interesting is
there was a baby that was thrown out with
the bathwater when they came to Israel
is that these people are fanatical about
expunging any vestige of a European
antisemitic stereotype in Israel.
We were going to be muscular and feisty
and we're not going to lock ourselves in
a head or studying taught
mode or anything like that.
We're going to be out in the
fields farming and fighting
and defending our, our,
our land was, and in many ways, I
think it was an abrogation of, of, of,
of many things that are Jewish by the way.
You can be both,
right and you can stand up for yourself
and also study. You can, you can do both.
Um,
one of the stories I tell in the book
or just kind of interesting is my first
year I,
you know,
I did nothing Jewish growing up except
for fasting on Yom Kippor for whatever
reason. It was kind of an easy
thing to understand. We're Jews.
We fast on Yom Kippur. That's our
thing. I did nothing else. I was a,
but I did that and it was kind
of, I don't know, a challenge.
I don't know what it
was, but that the, uh,
the first time I didn't fasten your group,
who was my first Yankee Kippor at the
academy. It was a feast. It was a feast.
I knew board the kibbutzniks,
you know, made a write in
the book. Uh, you know, uh,
grilled cheese sandwiches was the
thing which was really ham and cheese.
So I didn't want to shock anybody
but of what it was. Wow. So they,
so you illustrate that point,
meaning that they were really going out
of their way to erase any connection to
religion even though they had come to
a country to be safe because they were
persecuted for their religion. I mean,
there's like real psychological stuff,
but here's the interesting irony is
he was a very unknownst
attempt to erase that history.
You don't keep pro was
still an anchor point.
It was a day of rebellion
against our ancestors.
So we were still orbiting the
same death star, so to speak.
We just in the opposite order.
But we hadn't gone off into space,
which is actually really good news if
you want to rekindle a Judaism. And,
and I think a lot of the ethic of the
Israel Defense Forces is Jewish despite
itself. Um, and you know, so, so one,
one of the, you know, toward the,
when I started flying in reserves was a
very kind of ethically fraught period in
for the air force in Israel. And, and
these are dilemmas that now, you know,
our colleagues in the US
air force and navy face,
and then the British air force
we're all facing these day,
which is how do you fight a war in
civilian areas when your enemy can dictate
exactly where that war is going to be fun.
If you're launching rockets out of
schools and hospitals at civilian targets,
how are you supposed to contend with,
with that challenge?
And it's tough and there are no
perfect answer to that. Um, but, uh,
you know, one of the stories we talk
about is his, uh, there was a, uh,
uh,
a Hamas planner named [inaudible] who
had been responsible for really hundreds
of, of civilian deaths in Israel. There
was a kind of a way of, of bus bombings,
primarily bus bombings, but
also restaurants, cafes,
cause there's like late nineties, this
is early 2006 when we come the second,
second, second Intifada. Exactly. Uh,
and we had tried to target this
guy and a number of times and
our rules of engagement were,
were clear enough to the
enemies is that are on our ride.
It was a very kind of
a cat and mouse game.
As we kinda got more nuanced in
finessing the rules of engagement.
It only took a few weeks
for the other side.
It was whether it was his Bella and in
Lebanon or Hamas in Gaza to understand,
um, how close could we bomb to civilian
targets? How close could we bomb to UN,
uh, facilities, what types of munitions
we could use in these situation?
There's kind of very clear
and we tipped our hand in, in,
in many ways I think maybe
so when we see this on the media,
during the war that Israel has bombed all
of this stuff and they show you all of
this destruction, you're really
missing the subutex. I mean,
I think a certain amount of people,
I try to tweet about it,
at least these show that, you know, they
dropped, they dropped leaflets saying,
you guys gotta get out of this house
because there's people, you know,
text messages, text message. I mean,
no army in the history of the world
would do anything like this ever.
You Israelis keep doing it and there,
and as you're saying,
they're enemies actually take advantage
of that over intentionally. They,
which is now they put bombs in
hospitals and they say, well,
what are you going to do knowing that
the world will be more than happy to
condemn the Jews,
right. By the way, which to me is okay
to ignore it. It's okay to ignore it.
We need to defend ourselves and you know,
you mean ignore the media outrage or
something? Yeah, yeah. I mean it's, it's,
it's there and I think we sometimes pay
a little bit too much attention to it.
The same critics weren't doing much when
we were being exterminated right now
that we're defending ourselves,
we're going to not take their advice.
We're going to do this the way we
want to do it ethically, ethically,
but not to appease a European critic
or the UN or anything like that,
but to do this Jewishly and there is a
way to do it and it's not clean and it's
not simple and these dilemmas are real
and you're not going to solve them in any
perfect way. Uh, so you know, the, the,
you know,
the kid get the kind of frustration
of not being able to get this guy and
watching buses blow up children killed
over and over again with his fingerprints
on, on, on, on, on each of these
is a very tough thing to go.
When we finally got a shot at him,
uh, there was an intelligence failure,
uh, and we hit the house that he was
in. It was on the outskirts of, of a,
of Gaza City. Uh, but 14 people
were there and that we'd,
and none of them were civilians
and Israel erupted and outrage.
And this is not therapy.
We don't need the UN in the Europeans to
tell us when those problems, right? Yeah.
Two class action lawsuits against the
Israeli air force by Jewish Israeli civil
rights groups. Um, 27
pilots quitting, right?
It was the kind of famous, the pilot's
letter, which was kind of a pub,
the open letter published in the
newspaper saying, we're, we're,
we're stepping down from active service.
Uh,
and this became a morale
crisis in the air force.
And the way we addressed it, and this
to me is it's sort of the connection,
it's why these, these stories
are, are, are, are in there,
is done hollow too with the time was,
was the commander of chief of the air
force did a tour of the various bases and
wings of, of, of the air
force to do a debriefing.
Debriefing is a, is a, is a, a,
um, almost a religious ritual in the
Israeli air force. It's a very, very,
uh, rigorous, painful,
methodical kind of, uh, um,
for every ton Bluetick exercise of going
through everything that went wrong.
Some of the things that went right but
mainly went, went wrong. And how do we,
how do we improve? And, and it, it, it's a
rank blind and he put himself out there
and he came to our, where the wing that,
that, that, that, that
conducted the operation.
And so he started with us and they were
about 50 people in the room and we had
an almost all night session,
which started with his debriefing but,
but progress very quickly into a kind
of an ethical debate as to how do we
conduct ourselves. Um,
and the way I describe it,
which I think some of my colleagues who
read a thing could think of was it's
pretty accurate. And it was the
2002, so sometimes fast. Um,
a friend of mine from theU
s navy read it and said,
what you guys conducted would be
mutiny in, in, in our organization.
And I understand that,
I understand it because it was a complete
subversion of the hierarchy in pursuit
of a truth and ethical
truth, which is elusive. Um,
but it is a very Jewish way to conduct
yourself. It's not hierarchical.
It is a crowds wisdom that is guiding us.
And that doesn't mean you're
going to get perfect answers.
And our answers have not been perfect
since then, but they've improved.
And we're also, it provided real
clarity on how we navigate this dilemma.
What do we define as Optima?
Right? You can't, on the one hand,
please the virtue of truth and
tell the bride that she's ugly.
Uh, and at the same time,
the virtue of humanity,
you're going to have to navigate Optima
and that's life, right? And against it,
it's a very Jewish exercise and it's
how we conduct ourselves to say that we
solved, we solved that, but this, this
is the way we muddle through, um, in,
in Judaism and to me that there's value
in that it was not extinguished by our
socialists founders. So it's
interesting that you said that, um,
that we should just ignore
or that Israelis should just
ignore the media portion
of this.
Cause that always seems to be a huge
part of any of this in the Middle East at
any time. It's like, oh, every it,
there's just this endless focus or this
absurdly tiny piece of land with no,
virtually no natural resources.
I guess they found natural
gas in the last 10 years,
but for most of their history
had no, certainly had no oil. Um,
this like obsessive focus where it's like
they're just kind of live in and going
on and doing their thing.
And I guess maybe we should all probably
pay less attention to the media.
I think that that's probably the Jews
are doing a great job of controlling the
media, I guess. That's
right. That's right. Yeah.
We've lost control of the media.
That's,
that's the bigger problem here
too by the, to be clear, we joke,
I have a Palestinian business part, right?
Uh, Macona in a Palestinian business.
We joke about this, the Palestinians
get this as well. By the way. I,
and I think my partner
was, it was, today's is a,
is a close friend I think also sees it
as part of the Palestinian problem is
that, you know, I'm a, I'm
a pro Palestine guy. I,
I'd love to see a
Palestinian state tomorrow.
The challenge for the Palestinians
is very much the same as it is.
Our challenge is they need
to define themselves in a
framework that is something
other than victimhood take away the Jews.
What are the Palestinians exactly that
if they continue to define themselves
with us as the backdrop,
then never going to be anybody.
And there's so much potential to build
something exciting, uh, uh, in Palestine.
And in many ways when we
talk about the media, I mean,
maybe it's too strong a term,
we should ignore it. Um,
we're all complicit in that,
in perpetuating that human failure in
the Middle East. We're complicit in it.
We're placing no demands on the Arab
world to take some sort of responsibility
for its future. It's so easy to say, oh,
it's the Jews' fault over and over
again at some point that rings hollow in
Israel. So we start ignoring it in the
Arab world. You know, if, if you're,
if you're, it's a very
intoxicating notion, right?
Is If someone sells you victimhood,
it's something that's kind of easy to
embrace, but at the end of the day,
it's toxic.
You should steer away from
it. Yeah. And interestingly,
I think that does ring back to the
way you were defining sort of an old
antisemitism that's now thrust on Israel
because Egypt can bomb the hell out of
the border of Gaza and blow up tunnels
and do whatever they want. No one cares.
Saudi Arabia can bomb the hell out of
Yemen and kill thousands and thousands of
people and cause of famine and nobody
cares. Genocide in Darfur. Yeah.
And so there's this odd asymmetry
there. Uh, well there's an asymmetry.
There's literally symmetry
in the powers of both sides,
which is being used against each other.
And then there's an asymmetry of media
and everything else. So it does have that,
that one through line that these,
these weird people kind of
survived through this thing.
Look who the, who the real victims
are right there. Black Sudanese there,
Yemeni civilians,
every Iraqi civilians or Syrian civilians.
These are the real victims because
they're not getting attention, right?
We're not, no, no.
You and them resolutions coming in
lately on dark for our or anything.
We're very focused on, on a problem
that I don't think it is a huge problem.
In fact, we're probably contributing
more to its perpetuation, then it's
it's solution. Yeah. All right. So
let's finish with, with some of the,
the future of how this stuff can work out.
I have a sense of how you think it
can work out on the Israeli side.
They just have to sort of keep
going basically, I think, and, and,
and sort of reconcile,
I think what you think those
three different pillars
of society are that which
is not easy and yeah.
Yeah.
Would you say that's a bigger problem
for them than the external pressures?
Much, much bigger. Yeah. In fact,
it's the only thing I'm really
frightened of in Israel.
I don't think the
Palestinian issue sinks us.
I don't think the Iranians sink us.
I don't think the Greater Middle East
thing says we sink ourselves. Um, yeah.
I think the good news is it's
the same medicine in Israel,
in the United States, it's,
it's gotta be about Judaism.
We didn't come to start a Jewish state
just to have another democracy in the
world. This is the Jewish state.
It's the nation state of the Jews.
What does that mean for Dave Rubin,
who's not a citizen of that state?
But as a Jew, we are the
his self proclaimed nation
state. What does that mean?
What's our responsibility to him?
These are questions that we haven't really
answered and they're not just Israeli
questions. They're, they're,
they're Jewish questions.
So ultimately I think we're all engaged.
Israeli American and rest of
world Jewry in the same exercise,
which is good news because we don't have,
you know,
a dozen different prescriptions.
It's one, it's one.
The exercise is we need to define
Judaism for the 21st century.
What does that mean exactly?
Who's in, who's out? How'd
you get in? Had you leave?
Um, and what I, I don't actually
put down a definition for Judaism.
I put down a mechanism
because the definition should
evolve. It should be static.
Whatever I say today is
probably wrong to start with,
but certainly we'll be wrong,
you know, 10 years from now,
what's important is that
we have a mechanism for
continuing to refine and hone
our,
the definition of what Jewish is.
And the last section of the book is
exactly that. I'll leave it as a story
surprise cause because you
wrote a book. I got it. Got It.
Well, it's been a pleasure
chatting with you, I think.
I think this is a really fascinating
thing because it permeates so many of the
issues that I talk about just related
because this is related to free speech.
It's related to oppression and perceived
depression and freedom and liberty and
all of these things in
history and the rest of it.
So I've thoroughly enjoyed this, so thanks
for coming today. For more on Talia,
you can follow him on Twitter or like
you're not a big Twitter or Facebook.
That's wrong.
That's why you got a big smile because
you're not doing Twitter that often.
You can follow them on Twitter.
It's t Keenan.